[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parler sport sur tv78 et en Podcast
l'émission ne'est surtout pas manqué si
vous êtes un passionné de sport local
nos chroniqueurs sont avec nous n sur ce
plateau et ils sont en pleine forme
croyez-moi présentation en musique de la
dream team on commence à ma droite
musique c'est un véritable guerrier un
guerrier toujours très élégant il sera
et toujours très élégant en 2023 il le
sera tout a temps en 2024 c'est le si de
Russell crro notre gladiateur Pierre
Chevalier du Rugby Club de Versailles
est avec nous pendant une heure for et
bonheur maximous bonne année les amis
bonne année ravi de redémarrer cette
année olympique sur les chapeau de rou
avec vous tous on va se régaler quelles
sont vos résolutions pour l'année 2024
faire du sport Faire du sport plus de SP
faire du sport de très haut niveau de
très haut niveau et peut-être bosser un
peu les sujets pour les émissions on
continue à gauche musique vous
reconnaissez sa musique en 2024 il
continuera à nous éblouir sur sa
connaissance du sport italien et sur sa
connaissance du sport yvelinois c'est
notre encyclopédie notre Italian lover
GR est avec nous pendant heure comment
allez-vous ça va bonjour Michel bonjour
Pier bonne année à toutes et à tous à
tous les les passionnés de sport
yvelinois qui nous regarde écoutez ça va
très bien j'en parlerai tout à l'heure
il y a une échéance qui approche et
qu'on attend avec impatience celle des
Jeux Olympique donc voilà 2024 s'ouvre
sous de de bonnes augures une résolution
peut-être pour 2024 un peu plus de sport
une meilleure alimentation meilleure
hygiène de
vie voilà le sport ça va je je pratique
assez souvent mais on va dire une
meilleure hygiène de vie un peu plus
globale un meilleur sommeil manger mieux
c'est toujours voilà de des bonnes
résolutions qu'on prend en début d'année
on a on a du mal à s'y tenir il faut le
et des bons pronostic peut-êt et
peut-être aussi des bons pronostics
effectivement on termine juste à côté de
vous grégoryi mesdames et messieurs il
sera encore la superstar de cette
émission en 2024 c'est une légende
vivante ses analyses sont toujours
précises ces punchlines sont mythiques
on a de la chance de l'avoir sur cette
émission Jean Miss ex-entraîneur
de plaisir plaisir club est avec nous
pendant bonjour 1 heure comment
allez-vous Jean et ben très bien bonne
année à tout le monde très heureux
d'être parmi vous ce début d'année ça
fait énormément plaisir résolution pour
vous gens de faire attention je met les
doigts d'accord ok le le message est
passé alors avant de passer au programme
de l'émission on va parler de course à
pied c'est une tradition dans le monde
de la course depuis 10 ans chaque début
janvier des milliers de coureurs
investissent la petite commune de cerner
la ville juste après les fêtes de fin
d'année ce dimanche 7 janvier ce sportif
venu de 61 départements et de l'étranger
viennent participer au premier marathon
et semi-marathon de France au programme
également un 10 km un meeting de
joellette un vrai succès pour ce
rendez-vous qui se déroule au cœur de la
Vallée de Chevreuse on écoute
l'organisateur on s'est dit si on veut
avoir du monde il faut que maintenant
les les coureurs cherchent un petit peu
de sel dans leur course à pied cherchent
des défis et on s'était dit ben si on
fait ça au mois de mai juin on aura pas
grand monde par contre si on fait ça
tout de suite après les fêtes on peut
avoir du monde on a commencé avec 200
coureurs en 2014 et là pour les 10 ans
on a refusé du monde et on a bloqué à
1600 personnes euh du côté du marathon
plus de 400 courageux ont pris le départ
de l'épreuve cette année chez les
féminines Garance Perro s'impose en 3h 4
minutes et 36 secondes chez les hommes
la course a été remporté par le
villepreusien Nicolas duil en
2h41es et 5 secondes les Vinois s'impose
pour la deuxème fois consécutive dans
l'épreuve alors votre avis sur cette
course on valide ou pas
messieur on valide tout le monde valide
Jean pourquoi vous validez alors moi je
moi je valide pour trois raisons là
pourquoi pour rigoler je v pour tris
raisons la première c'est parce que nous
l'avons fait avec Pierro tous les deux
bon on nous a pas vu à l'antenne là mais
nous y étions c'est parce qu'on pas
super perf mais nonon faut reconnaître
faut reconnaître on n pas été non plus
au top mais on reviendra l'année
prochaine plus fort la deuxième parce
que l'organisateur est un copain que je
connais depuis très longtemps et que
c'est une très très très belle
organisation et qui qui dure depuis un
un certain temps il l'a dit lui-même 10
ans voilà depuis c'est je crois que
c'était le 10è anniversire 10 édition C
oua ouais 10e édition euh et qui réunit
il a dit lui-même de plus en plus en
plus de de de de de candidats et de
participants plutôt et et donc on est on
est on est heureux de voir ce genre de
de compétition qui est pas vraiment
c'est une compétition sans sans lettres
c'est vraiment on va dire un détox après
fête où tout le monde oui certains nous
l'ont dit hein ils ont mangé peut-être
un peu trop d'hîre de fois gras et du
coup ils viennent sur la compétition
ouais tout tout à fait tout à fait ça
réuni c'est plus le petit côté la petite
sortie la petite course et quand même
bon semi-marathon c'est pas non plus
mais mais Mar marathon semiarathon et
marathon bien sûr 10 K mais euh voilà et
mais c'est ça réunit de plus en plus de
monde il il a ét obligé de de freiner
donc pour ces trois raisons je dis bravo
et que ça continue quoi pierre moi deux
raisons la
première Jan l'a rappelé l'a rappelé
déjà euh c'est c'est la troisème tu as
raison trè trois raisons euh non la
première c'est c'est je je suis
admiratif de de la période choisie pour
cet événement là effectivement juste
après les fêtes avec en plus un gagnant
un gagnant du marathon qui je crois
termine en 221 2h 41 minutes et 5
secondes 241 il avait déjà gagné l'année
d'avant je crois et là là il c'est 2h 41
juste après le réveillon et Noël donc ça
chapeau chapeau à toutes les
particiy pasire il a pas dû le faire
même manre pas la même il a pas non plus
le même physique sur ce que j'ai vu il
il est plutôt long et est lancé bon ce
qui correspond à peu près à nos
physiques aussi hein mais nous a dit
quand même à la fin que son temps bon il
pouvait pas faire mieux mais qu'il était
habitué quand même à faire moins de 2h
minut pour nous ça a été un problème de
chaussures des chaussures qui étaient
pas qui étaient pas bonnes la deuxème
raison c'est que particulièrement dans
une année
olympique je crois que ça ça ça montre
encore un peu plus le la vogue du sport
du sport santé sport bien-être et de
pratiquer une activité physique le plus
régulièrement possible et là il y en a
vraiment plein plein de coureurs et de
coureuses qui se qui choisissent qui
choisissent le semi-marathon le marathon
il y en a de plus en plus dans les dans
les calendriers ils ont donc tout et
tous le le choix dans la date et dès le
début de l'année en plus dès le début
2024 juste après les réveillons de de
pouvoir s'aligner sur une course bon les
les performances passent au second plan
mais en tout cas chapeau à
l'organisateur c'est c'est B c'est une
une belle manifestation du sport pour
tous dans les ivelines en plus sur une
année olympique très bien et vous ne
dites pas ça parce que c'est un émid Gan
qui a organisé aussi je dis aussi ça
parce que c'est un éid Gan
les amis les amis de nos amis sont nos
amis moi j'ai envie de dire déjà bravo à
eux parce que juste après les fêtes
effectivement faut être courageux pour
aller digérer tous les les bons mecs
qu'on a pu manger pendant les fêtes moi
je m'étais programmé un petit un petit
voilà programme de footing au final
benah j'ai rien respecté donc déjà bravo
c'est pour ça que c'était une bonne
résolution d'un point de vue moi
marketing je trouve que c'est bien on
avance cette course comme le premier
marathon de l'année ça permet aussi de
pouvoir parler de de cette course dans
un cadre aussi exceptionnel qui est
cette vallée de Chevreuse qu'on loue
souvent pour les parcours cyclistes mais
il y a aussi de beaux endroits pour
courir voilà ça permet aussi de de de
découvrir ce département des evelines et
d'un point de vue sportif ce serait la
troisème raison euh point de vue sportif
on a quand même une course qui est de
plus en plus relevée là Nicolas Dua et
garansperro c'est des coureurs qu'on
retrouve dans les les les gros trail de
de la région lesco trail on les a aussi
vu lors de la dernière le dernier trail
à aloncour quand ils avaient aussi gravi
cette colline je crois que c'était
Nicolas du d'ailleurs qui avait remporté
ce ce TR donc voilà c'est des habitués
qu'on retrouve il y a aussi des coureurs
étrangers des coureurs venus de de toute
la France donc on a quand même un plate
Argentine il y avait des argentins qui
étaient en vacances en France et qui
sont venus ils ont vu tout simplement
l'information sur sur les réseaux
sociaux ils sont venus courir donc
quasiment un an plus tard la France a
pris sa revanche sur l'Argentine dans un
autre sport voilà non en tout cas voilà
plein de d'aspects positifs pour une
course qui dure des désormais depuis
depuis une dizaine d'années donc longue
vie encore à elle oui la date finalement
c'est peut-être ça aussi qui fait que ça
fonctionne peut-être Jean le fait que ça
soit le premier marathon de l'année oui
c'est certain et puis en plus c date
juste après les fêtes c'est ça ça fait
c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure c
un peu le la course des intox quoi
c'està dire on va on va aller là-bas
comme ça on va on va éliminer quoi on va
éliminer et voilà j'ai mis le doigt
dessus mais c'est très important c'est
vrai qu'on a beaucoup parlé du marathon
mais c'est éétait une course aussi qui
s'adressait à à beaucoup de coureurs
même des coureurs moin aguérés par
exemple comme moi mais on on pouvait
aussi se tourner vers un 10 km le 10 km
c'est quand même à la portée c'est il
faut quand même être entraîné mais c'est
à la portée de d'un peu plus de monde ça
permet de rassembler un peu plus au
final je crois qu'il y a plus de 1000
personnes qui ont participé il y avait
la course de joelette le côté aussi un
peu festif le rassemblement de joelette
donc ça permet de d'être le plus
rassembleur possible aussi ça veut dire
surtout aussi que à cette période de
l'année la plupart des des cours
couruses ont eu peu de temps de se pour
se préparer pour s'entraîner pour se
préparer en plein hiver c'est pas c'est
pas la période la plus sympa un pe
peut-être aussi sur sur la météo la
météo il faisait très froid dimanche ou
mais c'est pas mais il il pleuvait pas
forcément pleuvait plus il pleuvait plus
mais ça c'est c'est plutôt pas mal c'est
plutôt pas mal il faut il faut
s'échauffer évidemment il faut il faut
rentrer un petit peu dans une demi-heure
deauement VO et puis et puis ça Perm ça
permet quand même ça vivifie là pour le
coup et ça ça permet à la limite de de
d'assurer une mini perf parce que il
fait pas trop chaud quoi voilà avec avec
du vent de face par contre il y avait du
vent de face donc ça a ralenti certain
Jean et moi on a pas eu ce problème là
il y a pas de portance donc c'est c'est
pas pas très grave on vous filmera
l'année prochaine du coup Pierre et Jean
on vous filmera avec plaisir alors une
11e édition en tout cas est déjà
programmé pour l'année prochaine sera
organisé cette fois-ci le 5 janvier 2025
ça sera légèrement plus tôt que cette
année il faudra donc être beaucoup plus
raisonnable he pendant les les fêtes de
de fin d'année et notamment sur les
huîtres et le foig GR anger la galette
voilà il faud attendre pour pour manger
la galette exactement à la fin deseff on
pourra peut-être manger cette galette
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler du PSG k Mbappé doit-il
quitter le PSG greégory canalé nous fera
une magnifique envolé sur 2024 une année
olympique dans les zivlines mais avant
de parler de ces thèmes on va parler de
cyclisme sur
piste on va donc continuer par du
cyclisme sur piste le vélodrome national
vibré pendant 4 jours au rythme des
championnats de France 4 jours au 140
sportifs venus des quatre coins de la
France se sont affrontés sur la future
piste olympique de 50 ans en Eveline
selon la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme le bilan est positif on écoute
le responsable des événements à la FFC
Nicolas André le centre piste a bien
vécu on a eu des des belles
retransmissions télé jusqu'au podium
protocolaire très apprécié on a pu
entendre des marseillaises à capella
avec des spectateurs qui ont poussé la
voix et je crois que côté organisation
côté public
billetterie avec le soutien de de
l'agglomération de 5quen1 et du
département des Yvelines on a réussi à
un beau championnat de France pour
débuter l'année
2024 au total plus de 5000 spectateurs
sont venus sur les 4 jours de
compétition pour assister à cet
événement organisé pour la 2uxe fois
dans la structure après 2019 parmi ceux
qui ont fait vibrer le public on
retrouve Tom de rche le PIST star de
l'équipe de France à porter deux titres
de champion de France sur le Kerin et le
kilomètre une bonne répétition pour les
athlètes tricolor en vue des prochains
mois
voir si si on a progressé cet hiver on a
bien travaillé et je pense qu' a de
belles choses qui qui sontessorties et
voilà de se confronter aussi on fait on
fait du sport de ha niveau pour se
confronter au meilleur donc là il y a eu
des belles batailles avec avec les
collègues je pense aussi au match avec R
en vitesse ening où ça a bien matché
cétait vraiment une bonne semaine sur ce
pointl euh du côté euh du positif du
côté de l'organisation et des athlètes
mais il y a eu quelques déceptions déjà
le public il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
monde hein vous l'avez vu dans les
tribunes le jeudi et le dimanche
seulement 400 spectateurs dans les
tribunes euh le jeudi et le dimanche
1000 euh un peu plus de 1000 le vendredi
et le samedi autre déception le la non
participation de Mathilde gros et de
Sébastien viget tous les deux malades la
question sur cette thématique est-ce que
c'est un TOP ou un flop c'est
championnat de France au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en
Iline mitigé pour vous gens mitigé pour
vous pierre
et pour vous non du coup ENF top top
pour vous pas flop en tout cas pas flop
top alors pierre pourquoi pour pour
reposer le sportif et le festif dans une
année où justement on va on mise
gros sur le sur le le spectacle euh à à
6 mois à 6 7 mois des des Jeux
Olympiques sportivement c'était une
revue d'effectif ça avit ça avait tout
l'air et vous l'avez cité d'une
répétition générale avant avant les J ou
surtout avant les Championnats d'Europe
là qui ont qui ont lieu la semaine
prochaine la semaine prochaine ce
commence aujourd'hui voà donc voà
commencer aujourd'hui donc répétition
générale des effectifs avec les nos deux
grosses tes d'affiches absentes absentes
pour maladie et de l'autre côté c'est a
une une répétition générale de la
pétence plutôt là du public français
pour pour les événements de cyclisme sur
piste bon ben là avec le bémol que ça
s'est déroulé pendant la deè 2è semaine
des vacances scolaires et donc les
peut-être que les Français étaient plus
en famille à la
campagne peut-être au sport d'hiver que
dans un V au Vélodrome de sa-quentin les
années les allées sonnent sonnent un peu
creux quoi donc en terme en terme de
public c'est c'est un démarrage timide
de l'année olympique mais il faut il
faut se souvenir que Ben les Jeux
Olympiques c'est pour c'est pour
accueillir la planète entière donc on
peut on peut imaginer que le vélodrome
de Saint-Quentin en juillet en août et
en septembre sera rempli plus par des
spectateurs étrangers qui viendront qui
viendront faire le voyage en France pour
l'instant les Français ne semblent pas
encore totalement mobilisés ou concernés
par le cyclisme sur piste à
saintquentintion pour vous oui oui parce
que parce que on en parle souvent c'est
le le vélodrome de SaintQuentin doit
vivre par le cyclisme il y a il y a
d'autres événements qui sont organisés
mais pour l'instant ça fait pas encore
totalement recette euh bon avec les
têtes d'affiches le le l'enjeu olympique
et et puis la planète à accueillir je
pense que là là pour le coup ça sera
quand même beaucoup plus plein euh cet
été après on m'a dit quand même dans
dans les tribunes au niveau de
l'organisation qu'il y a pas forcément
beaucoup de monde sur des championnats
de France là ça paraissait vite parce
que forcément le vélodrome est très
grand mais d'habitude il sont sur les
plus petits vélodromees genan qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez
oui je sa pas c'est pas une excuse mais
bon non c'est regrettable quand même moi
je trouve que c'est regrettable parce
que c'est un championnat national alors
se contenter en disant oui mais c'est
normal parce que il y a pas trop de
monde non je crois qu'il vaut mieux
quand même voir voir plus grand et
surtout qu'on est Pierre l' dit dans une
année olympique où je pense que Ben le
choix de la date de ce championnat était
peut-être pas le plus à pri le le le
plus le plus adapté parce que justement
très mal placé en période scolaire à
proximité des fêtes et pour faire venir
du monde du monde c'est pour faire
connaître peut-être un petit peu plus
avance avant l'échéance des Jeux
Olympiques ben c'était peut-être
l'occasion de de de mettre le le
cyclisme sur piste sous les projecteurs
là làon c'est un peu dommage c'est un
petit peu dommage c'est c'est un
championnat national les les les têtes
d'affiche les grandes stars qui sont pas
venus et qui sont malades ça il pouvait
pas le savoir avant donc c'est pas ça
Mathilde gros par exemple déclaré
forfait quasiment la dernière minute ça
donc c'est pas parce que il ne sont pas
venus que les gens ne sont pas venus au
Vélodrome ça rien à voir ça donc c'est
un petit peu regrettable pour moi parce
que encore une fois c'était l'occasion
de les mettre en avant et de faire
peut-être un peu plus découvrir cette
discipline on se souvent dans cette
émission on on le dit parce que ça ça
manque le spectateur le vélodrome ça
manque énormment le spectateur c'est
pour ça que on fait même d'autres
d'autres d' d'autres animation et
d'autres activités autre que sportive
pour attirer un petit peu plus de monde
dans cet endroit en plus qui est qui qui
est magnifique quoi il faut le
reconnaître donc alors c'est sûr les
Jeux Olympiques Pier l'a dit il y aura
du monde mais c'est dommage pour pour
nos championnats nationaux grgoryi
est-ce qu'on peut être déçu oui vous
pour vous c'est un TOP non j'ai dit que
c'était pas un flop j'ais pas jusquà
dire un top estce est-ce qu'on peut être
déçu oui est-ce qu'on doit être surpris
je ne pense pas ça a été rappelé ils ont
pas forcément eu le choix dans la date
pour programmer ces championnats de
France on est quand même dans une année
olympique où euh il y a un calendrier
qui est très rempli pour les athlètes
français voilà pour qu' athlètes
français mais aussi athlètes
internationaux pour qu'il puissent
qualifier pour pour ses Jeux Olympiques
on a eu l'UCI track Champions League qui
est passé plus récemment les
championnats de de BMX Freestyle
championnat de France et on devait faire
ces championnats de France avant les
Championnats d'Europe donc les dates
voilà il n'y avait pas de multiples
dates pour pour pouvoir programmer ces
ces championnats de France je dis qu'on
n pas surpris parce que finalement il se
retrouve à organiser ses championnats de
France sur le premer weekend de janvier
bah il y avait fort à parier qu'on
aurait pas de beaucoup de monde dans les
tribunes ça a pu peut-être s'équilibrer
sur l'ensemble de l'événement on parle
d'une jauge de 5000 spectateurs sur les
4 jours de compétition c'est pas une
réussite loin de là il faut il faut le
dire alors 5000 mais je pense qu'on
prend en compte aussi les personentr
dans l'air centrale avec 400 personnes
le jeudi 400 personnes le dimanche donc
j'ai envie de dire dire bon voilà il y
avait aussi effectivement ce ce ce ce
côté aussi négatif avec l'absence de
Mathilde gros qui est notre française
qui avait remportter une médaille d'or
lors des championnats du monde sur place
il y avait pas de Sébastien Vigier mais
il y avait quand même Marie divine Kamet
il y avait Benjamin Thomas il y avait
d'autres coureurs qui étaient là dire c
fois champion du monde aussi on le
rappelle exactement donc c'est pour ça
je dis pas totalement flop je pense que
les meubles ont été sauvés à mon sens
parce qu'il y avait pas non plus on va
dire toutes les conditions réuni pour
pouvoir organiser des champion
championnats de France avec une jauge
pleine de ce ce vélodrome national mais
c'était pas aussi l'occasion de voir les
pistars de l'équipe de France Jean
justement à quelques mois des des Jeux
olympiques de leur montrer justement que
le public français était derrière eux ah
mais oui les championnats nationaux
servent aussi à ça à montrer no sportifs
de haut niveau c'est à part mathil gros
Sébastien Vigier et quelquesuns ils
étaient quasiment tous là ben voilà
c'est pour ça donc c'est c'est c'est
encore une fois de plus euh un un sujet
qui que que que la Fédération devrait un
petit sur laquelle sur lequel il devrait
se pincher parce que justement quoi
pourquoi pourquoi alors que bah le
plateau le plateau de grand champion
était présent ben pourquoi pourquoi les
gens ne sont pas venus quoi donc il y a
il y a un réel il y a un réel problème
quand même sur sur la connaissance
peut-être et et l'appréciation de ce
sport il faut le reconnaître quoi c'est
encore une fois c'est pas la première
fois qu'on le dit sur le plateau on a
quand même du mal à faire venir un sport
trop confidentiel selon vous peut-être
trop confidentiel peut-être trop
technique ou
trop peut-être trop lassant aussi je
sais pas je je suis pas
je je suis pas un spécialiste Yan aurait
pu nous en parler Paris que lui c'était
le
spécialisteier mais je je ne sais pas
mais c'est vrai que pour moi qui qui
suis pas un spécialiste de la discipline
bon ça va un petit moment quoi
honnêtement voilà c'est j'ai j'ai j'ai
pas les éléments pour apprécier ce sport
à sa juste valeur Pierre Chevalier et
c'est généralement dans les années
olympiques que on a des des pics de des
pics d'audience sur le cyclisme sur PIST
sur route avec avec
justement cette cette mise sous
projecteur dont parlait Jano
avec avec la planète entière les
meilleurs qui sont vraiment là vous
connaissez mon mon mon affection pour le
cyclimme mais mais je dois dire que
comme j'aime le sport je je regarde
quand même aussi particulièrement sur
les années olympiques on na jamais
autant parlé de cyclisme sur piste par
exemple et de King quand quand nos
Français déjà été aux Jeux olympiques et
gagné en plus avec avec les Florient
Rousseau et autres c'était c'était les
grandes heures et les belles années et
on espère que que Vigier gros et consort
vont vont nous ramener ces médailles
qu'on attend qu'on attend depuis depuis
la relève le vélodrome de 50 an doit-il
accueillir un nouveau championnat de
France de cyclisme sur piste on va faire
rapidement un petit tour de de table
dans les prochaines années bah ça reste
quand même une enceinte référence c'est
l'enceinte qui va accueir les Jeux
Olympiques donc je espérés qu'il y aura
de nouveau des championnats de France au
moins des championnats de France pour
faire le comparatif entre championnat de
France et d'ut champ fois qu' les
accueill oui mais voilà mais on a on a
pu aussi faire le comparatif avec
d'autres compétitions comme les
championnats du monde où là le vélodrome
avait attiré assez facilement son public
avec des duels c'est vrai France contre
le le reste du monde peut-être que les
affiches étaient un peu plus alléchantes
aussi
pour un public aussi bien d'initié que
de non initié au de non initié au
cyclisme donc oui j' c'est un grand oui
les championnats de France doivent
retourner au Vélodrome et je l'espère à
une autre date je pense que sur une
année non olympique on on pourra avoir
une date un peu plus on va dire un peu
plus attirante pour le public
championnat de France à nouveau
vélodrome national de 50 ans yeline vous
votez pour oui oui oui oui je suis je
suis je suis d'accord avec Greg parce
que justement c'est quand même le le
l'entre du cyclisme sur piste en France
quoi pierre l'OP de France de golf a
lieu au golf national le la la finale du
du du championnat de France de rugby a
lieu au Stade de France donc là oui
championnat championnat de France
championnat de France sur piste au au
Vélodrome national ça semble ça semble
évident en tout cas le prochain grand
rendez-vous au Vélodrome national ce
sera les Jeux Olympiques il devrait y
avoir beaucoup plus de monde au
Vélodrome pour cette échéance he ça on
en est persuadé et on attend de belles
victoires françaises on va maintenant
parler football depuis début janvier
l'attaquant du PSG Kyan Mbappé est à 6
mois de la fin de son contrat avec le
club de la capitale le joueur formé à
Claire Fontaine dans les imines est
libre de s'engager où il veut ce qui
donne évidemment lieu à de multiples
rumeurs Mbappé peut rester au
pariss-germain il peut aussi partir du
côté de l'Espagne où le Real Madrid lui
fait les yeux doux depuis de nombreuses
années il peut aussi partir du côté de
l'Angleterre plusieurs clubs de Première
Ligue pourrait l'accueillir Mbappé
l'assû il n'a pas pris sa décision la
question sur cette thématique Mbappé
doit-il quitter le PSG messieurs oui ou
non oui pour vous Jean maintenant à la
fin de la saison à la fin de la saison
bien sûr oui oui partagez pour vous
allez non un petit duel
entre entre Jean et Pierre alors pierre
pourquoi alors pourquoi parce que parce
que parce que c'est notre c'est notre
joyeux national et que la les prises de
position de nasera alal rifi euh récente
dans l'équipe ou dans les ou dans les
différents supports là cette semaine sur
le sujet ne souffre pas d'équivoque ça
fait quand même quelques années donc 7
ans qu'il est au PSG euh il est il est
devenu non seulement le meilleur buteur
du du club mais en plus capitaine de
l'équipe de France avec euh avec la la
trajectoire que l'on que l'on lui
connaît euh Nasser met les petits plats
dans les grands pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir le garder il y a énormément de
choses qui sont fait qui sont fait pour
le pour le choyer et pour le et pour lui
lui donner l'envie de rester alors oui
en terme de calendrier là il est il est
libre de de choisir de choisir sa
destination à partir de fin juin donc la
la fin de son contrat actuel avec le PSG
on sait que le Real est sur les rangs
que Liverpool est sur les rangs donc
c'est parmi les plus grands clubs les
plus grands clubs au monde et Nasser se
bat lui avec ses avec ses avec ses armes
et elles sont elles sont nombreuses
quand même notamment avec avec des
moyens financiers important c'est le 4e
club en terme au niveau UFA en terme de
valorisation je liser les chiffres ça ça
donne le vertige c'est un club qu's ont
acheté 70 millions et qui vaut qui est
valorisé à plus de 4 milliards d'euros
maintenant donc on va dire que le
l'intelligencia du du du PSG a les
moyens a les moyens de de garder clian
Mbappé et si je devais citer une raison
pour lequelle il ne il ne doit pas
partir c'est pour c'est pour
faire en sorte que une partie de son
contrat sportif soit honoré c'estàdire
gagner la Ligue des Champions euh tant
qu'ils l'ont pas gagné je vois c'est
c'est un paris perdu de de QSI donc du
le le Qatar le Qatar et Nasser enaser en
tête après maintenant s'il la gagne
cette année ce qui est ce qui est encore
possible ce qu' s'il la gagne cette
année là là oui il là il pourra partir
par la grande porte mais je je pense que
l'histoire de de Kyan Mbappé malgré ce
qu'il peut dire en ce moment sur le
public français et sur le et sur sa sa
vie en ce moment en France elle
s'inscrit en France ou du moins elle se
finira en
France il ira sans doute à un moment ou
un autre c'est c'est peut-être encore
encore un peu tôt donc j'aurais tendance
à dire parce que parce qu'il nous manque
encore quelque chose à écrire qu'il ne
faudrait pas qu'il parte Jean qu'est-ce
que vous répondez alors Mo conissez il
doit partir pour vous oui alors 7 ans ça
fait 7 ans qu'il est au PSG donc pour
moi revient pas sur la qualité du joueur
on le sait c'est un immense joueur c'est
un très grand joueur mais c'est an 7 ans
qu'il est au PSG et là je vous annonce
de suite quand vous aviez dit vous aviez
dit tout à l'heure il a pas encore pris
sa décision il va pas la prendre ça ça
va traîner là on en a pour 6 mois là on
a pour 6 mois des rebondissements en
veux-tu en voilà donc là à donné je
pense qu'il faut certains le poussent
quand même à à donneré sa sa réponse
rapidement oui mais il la donnera pas on
le sait ça ça fait partie du jeu ça fait
partie là ça va traîner jusqu'à
quasiment la fin quoi jusqu'à la fin
donc je pense que là on on on on suuse
un petit peu on Suse un petit peu au
niveau du club à effectivement là je
veux pas revenir sur ce que Pirro a dit
mais ils ont mis les moyens ils mettent
encore les moyens ils ont des arguments
pour le faire rester je crois qu'il va
pas falloir non plus je vais rester
tranquille parce que je vais prendre un
carton sinon mais il va pas falloir non
plus trop trop
exagérer pour le retenir parce que un
moment donné il va falloir qu'il prenne
sa décision ou ou où il reste où il part
bon moi je crois que 7 ans
euh Pierro parlait de de la Coupe
d'Europe la Coupe d'Europe bon mais si
si le PSG la gagne cette année c'est
parfait il pourra partir la tête haute
par la grande porte mais je crois que
même s'il la gagne pas il faut qu'il
faut qu'il quitte le club même pour lui
pour son expérience professionnelle et
sportive je pense qu'aller voir un autre
championnat lui fera pas de mal non plus
parce que peut-être aussi qu' a une
certaine lassitude au sein au sein du
PSG
autant une lassitude de son côté que du
côté aussi peut-être des autres joueurs
parce que là on va dire que quian Mbappé
étouffe un petit peu l'actualité du PSG
quoi c'estàd que là pendant 6 mois on va
parler que de ça quoi que l'éventuel
transfert il reste ou il part donc là je
pense que ça desserre un petit peu le le
club voilà c'est tout après je reviens
encore une fois pas du tout sur le sur
le personnage et la qualité du du du
footballeur qu'il est greégory qui vous
a convaincu moi
ou non mais Prim avir j'étais plus du
côté de gens et je vais le le rester
alors il disait kililian on parle plus
de Kyan Mbappé que du PSG mais c'est
vrai on dit souvent Kilian Saint-Germain
plutôt que parisaingermain c'est ces
derniers temps moi je pense qu'il doit
partir 7 ans on sait que dans les
couples dans le mariage c'est une date
difficile à à franchir chaque année on
espère peut-être la bonne année pour la
Ligue des Champions pour le PSG mais
c'est vrai que le PSG se casse souvent
les dents moi je pense que pour son bien
personnel pour son évolution il a 25 ans
il est quand même je pense à un tournant
de sa carrière euh il est parmi les
meilleurs joueurs du monde s'il veut
franchir cette étape supplémentaire et
directement potentiel candidat pour le
Ballon d'Or il est déjà aujourd'hui mais
s'il veut franchir cette étape et gagner
le Ballon d'Or à mon avis il doit aller
dans une institution plus grande que
celle du parissaggermain on a souvent
critiqué d'ailleurs l'institution du
parissaggermain qui n'était pas du
standing des autres grand club européen
je pense que pour son bien personnel
aller voir effectivement un autre
championnat comment ça se passe ailleurs
alors que ce soit en Angleterre euh qui
est peut-être le championnat le plus
relevé en ce moment en Espagne avec des
clubs qui euh et bien sont sont parmi
les les meilleurs voilà le Real Madrid
moi je le vois très bien associer à un
vinitius par exemple Mbappé je le vois
très bien jouer avec Bellingham moi je
rêve déjà de de le voir associer à à ce
type de de grands joueur européens donc
c'est un tournant de sa carrière il doit
faire son choix là depuis le 1er janvier
effectivement il peut choisir librement
sa destination il se murmure peut-être
en coulisse aussi qu' pour vrai c'est
pas impossible renouveler son contrat
pour que le PSG récupère quand même une
indemnité dans son transfert parce qu'il
l'avait payé à l'époque 180 si je pas
180 million d'euros donc pour pas que le
le PSG le laisse partir gratuitement et
après oui effectivement le PSG de son
côté par la voix de son président
naserrifi a dit toute sa volonté de
garder Mbappé je veux que Kyan reste a
dit naseri il est au centre du projet ce
qui est bizarre c'est que K Mbappé n'a
pas pris la parole pour commenter ce qui
a dit son président alors on sait que il
s'exprime peu dans les médias mais ce
silence peut peut-être des fois un
silence peut dire beaucoup plus de
choses que quand on prend la parole donc
pour son évolution personnelle il est à
25 ans on veut qu'il soit Ballon d'Or on
veut qu'il gagne encore de nombreux
titres je pense qu'il doit partir du
paris-germain en tout cas normalement ça
ne devrait pas trop traîner he Gan il a
dit après le Trophée des champions si je
sais ce que je vais faire ça ne va pas
traîner on en
reparlera et vous le voyez où du coup
Jean en Espagne grégoryi par contre n'a
pas n'a pas parlé d'Italie ou j'étais
surpris non mais alors ce qui est vrai
parce qu'il a parlé d'un bon championnat
non pas les moyens non les le
championnat italien malheureusement par
rapport au championnat d'Espagne ou au
championnat d'Angleterre est peut-être
un peu moins relevé quoi que Mbappé a
toujours n'a jamais caché son amour pour
l'AC Milan mais bon je le vois pas tout
de suite peut-être un jour non mais
peut-être dans le cours de sa carrière
peut-être en fin de carrière mais là non
il doit clairement pas aller il doit
clairement pas aller euh en Italie je
verrais plutôt euh au Real au Real
puisque pour moi c'est c'est un club qui
lui qui lui correspond mieux et un
championnat qui lui correspond mieux par
rapport à son style de jeu je pense qu'à
Liverpool le champion anglais va se
faire un petit peu frotter les oreilles
pense que là apparemment Liverpool c'est
le le choix de sa mère sa mère aime
beaucoup Liverpool oui mais c'est pas sa
mère qui va jouer si non même pas mais
c'est de grand c'est deux grands
entraîneurs aussi c'est entre Ancelotti
et clop c'est c'est des entraîneurs qui
peuvent qui extrêmement expérimenter not
au niveau européen et qui peuvent
façonner encore un petit peu plus le le
diamant brut et puis nous le nous le
rendre encore un petit peu plus
compétitif encore si c'était possible
bon en tout cas on continuera à suivre
ce dossier brûlant dans les prochains
mois on espère qu'il prendra sa décision
plutôt possible on verra ça Jean nous a
dit que non on verra on verra on
continue à parler du parissgermain dans
cette émission les jeunes joueurs des
centres de formation et préformation du
PSG ont fait leur rentrée au campus de
poissi dimanche ils ont été accueillis
par le président Nasser el halaifi au
total ce sont 129 jeunes qui ont
découvert le centre d'entraînement avec
cette arrivée toutes les équipe du PSG
sont désormais réunies sur le site si
l'équipe professionnelle masculine était
déjà installée depuis juillet elle a été
rejointe par l'équipe féminine qui a
pris ses quartiers la semaine dernière
les féminines jouent ce jeudi contre le
losque dans ce Training Center le
terrain peut accueillir 700 spectateurs
dont 400 en tribune la question sur
cette thématique est-ce que c'est un
vrai plus pour le PSG que tout le monde
soit réuni sur le même lieu oui bon il a
il y a pas de débat prochain thème
Pierre Chevalier euh oui parce que parce
que c'est la formation La formation et
l'ambition au cœur de au cœur du système
du système
PSG je je me souviens de de notre
président Emmanuel Macron qui disait
qu'il fallait traverser la rue pour
avoir un emploi bah là les les les les
futurs jeunes pous et futurs talents du
PSG donc à donc à traverser une allée
pour être au contact des prof
professionnel les garçons les garçons et
les filles et et dans dans une dans une
structure qui est qui est franchement a
priori je l'ai pas encore visité je l'ai
pas encore visité mais je passe devant
souvent qui est
vraimentent il y a du vent il y a le
bruit de l'autoroute mais mais c'est
quand même flambon neuf et c'est et là
pour le coup le PSG peut se targuer
d'avoir le le le plus beau et le le
meilleur centre d'entraînement au monde
d'ailleurs je crois que le match le
match des féminines c'est déjà joué
c'était c'était mardi c'est ce soir
contre le losque je je crois que c'est
6-0 ilelles ont gagné 6-0 alors ou alors
c'était l'année dernière mais c'est
c'est c'est je crois que c'est je crois
que c très bon pronos je crois que je
crois que ça s joué ENF en tout cas
c'est l'effet maison en plus l'effet
maison pour les pour les féminines va
enfin jouer et elles vont pouvoir elles
vont pouvoir après justement signer des
résultats là elles sont elles sont elles
sont pour l'instant que 3è on peut
imaginer qu'avec qu'avec des
installations et maintenant un stade
alors il y a que il y a que 700 places
700 places pour le stade des féminines
elles pourront avoir justement parlait
un moment d'un stade de 5000 6000 places
mais pour l'instant ils finement
finalement c'est c'est limité mais en
tout état de cause avoir toutes les
forces vives et toutes les catégories
d'âge du PSG au même endroit et dans
dans dans sur des installations de telle
qualité c'est c'est de toute façon la
signature même du projet du projet du
PSG Grégor juste signaler que Pierre a
touttalement totalement raison 6-0
première victoire premier match à
domicile pour pour les Parisiennes dans
ce nouveau campus PSG première victoire
contre le losque 6-0 bah moi je suis oui
je suis d' de de mes amis de mes
camarades parce que euh j'ai RII voilà
mais il semble que il me semble que tu
avais mis la petite raquette verge non
tout simplement parce que le PSG se
rapproche du standing des grands clubs
les grands clubs ont leur centre
d'entraînement avec toutes les équipes
qui sont réunies en leur sein alors
c'est marrant que Pierre fasse la la
référence de d'Emmanuel Macron qui
disait il faut traverser la rue
effectivement dans l'ancien camp d'loges
il fallait traverser la rue pour se
rendre dans les différentes parties de
de ce camp Desloges qui était en fait
pas vraiment un centre d'entraînement
c'était assez éclaté euh entre les
terrains utilisés par les jeunes les
terrains utilisés par les pros les
féminines elles carrément elles étaient
à Bougival donc on avait un club qui
était un peu éclaté à en plusieurs
endroits donc d'avoir tout le monde
réuni euh sur sur un même campus euh il
y a eu les pros qui sont arrivés en
juillet les pros masculins les féminines
et désormais les petits je c'est vrai
que les petits jeunes d'être au contact
de pouvoir voir les les pros s'entraîner
être proche bah ça pe ça peut leur
donner de la suite la suite de la suite
dans les idées et et donc bah voilà
d'avoir maintenant ce ce campus de de
première qualité de de nouvelles
génération avec on le sait des des
équipements de de haute volet je pense
que c'est ça peut être qu'un plus pour
le club de réunir tout le monde en un
même endroit pierre disait que c'était
peut-être le plus beau centre
d'entraînement du monde vous
validez je reste quand même fan moi de
la mia du FC Barcelone c'est quand même
voilà il y a il y a beaucoup de de
centres très beau mais c'est vrai que là
on a un centre de de première qualité
dans les ivelines avec quelques petits
désagréments disait la dernière fois le
vent l'autoroute qui passe pas loin mais
en on va dire qualitativement au niveau
de la juste des terrains
désinstallations on est quand même sur
des équipements de premier plan Jean
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez rien à
rajouter il on tout dit ces magnifiquees
structur d'entraînement et et de
formation toutes les équipe de haut
niveau réunie dans ce même site sur ce
même site c'est c'est c'est c'est bien
pour tout le monde c'est bien pour les
équipes c'est bien pour le club parce
que ça ça montre aussi un club un petit
peu plus un petit peu plus uni entre
guillemets parce que là comme le disait
pierre tout à l'heure les équipes sont
pas éclatées à droite à gauche et et
donc un club qui est un peu plus un peu
plus uni et et qui et et qui va dégager
une sérénité un petit peu plus positive
que que qu'elle ne peut faire jusqu'à
présent avec des des équipes un petit
peu partout mais pu c'est magnifique il
est moderne il est il est magnifique et
tout tout VO bien quoi on peut pas
rajouter grand chose que ce qui a été
dit on va passer du coup à la prochaine
thématique on va maintenant parler à
basket vous vouliz dire quelque chose ou
non non c'était c'était rajouté en fait
que dans le projet la la c'est une c'est
une c'est une contrainte en moins avec
ce sur la partie entraînement et que il
y reste maintenant une une énorme
contrainte qui est celle du stade donc
le Parc des Princes ou le Stade de
France mais a priori nasser est plus sur
le Parc des Princes et espère que les
négociations avec la Ville de Paris vont
aboutir parla de football nou pas que
les judoka et lesballur aussi vont
intégrer ce ce centre ce campus de poiss
dans dans les prochains mois alors on va
maintenant parler basket et de notre
prodige ivelinois Victor waniama si les
San anono Spurs sont toujours à la peine
avec seulement 5 victoires en 30 matchs
disputé Victor enchaîne les records il
vient de rentrer dans le cercle très
fermé des joueurs plus de 100 contes en
moins de 35 matchs c'est seulement le 6e
joueur de l'histoire à le faire il est
notamment au côté d'une légende du
basket Shaquille oil il a aussi le
record du plus du plus jeune joueur de
l'histoire de la NBA avec au moins 20
points et 20 rebonds en un match à
seulement à 19 ans et 338 jours il a
fait 8 double doubl d'affilé un record
pour un joueur de moins de 20 ans il a
dépassé Dwight Howard qui était bloqué à
7 la question sur cette thématique
est-il déjà dans la légende de la NBA
oui ou non est-il déjà dans la légende
de la NBA la légende de la
NBA vous êtes partagé vous allez dire
oui pour vous Grégor plus sur le oui
forcément parce que allez on fait un
petit duel entre vous grégoryi et Pierre
grégoryi vous commenz mais ce qu'il faut
dire déjà c'est que la la wa Mania qu'on
qu'on lui prêtait voilà est au
rendez-vous en tout cas il est à la
hauteur des attentes si on prend ces ces
statistiques individuelles qui sont
affiché il est largement à la hauteur
des attentes il est en train de battre
tous les records voilà moyenne de 19,3
points 10,1 rebond 2,8 passes et 3,3
contre voilà c'est une vraie attraction
on attend avec impatience chaque année
maintenant c'est une tradition le match
du NBA qui se délocalise en France ça
sera pas cette année mais normalement
l'année prochaine peut-être que on aura
l'occasion de voir Victor banama avec
son maillot des Spurs fouler le parquet
de l'accord hôtel Arena de de Bercy ben
non il est à la hauteur des des attentes
de manière individuelle là on a vu bah
même musculairement il a quand même
changé depuis son passage de la France
vers les États-Unis on peut quand même
être frustré on le savait on le disait
quand il a alors c'est pas lui qui a eu
le choix des Spurs c'est les Spurs qui
l'ont sélectionné dans dans la draft qui
ont le premier choix de la draft on
disait la peut-être le point négatif
c'est qu'il va être dans une équipe qui
ne brille pas dernièrement NBL est
carrément dernière de sa conférence West
peut-être que lui peut être frustré
aussi sur son temps de jeu qui a un peu
baissé dernièrement il aimerait jouer un
peu plus on le sait aussi avec cette
équip équipe des Spurs il est même
rentré sur le terrain sans
l'autorisation de son coach Greg Popovic
lors d'un match donc attention à ne pas
être avoir un peu trop de défiance
envers son coach qui on le sait aussi
est un un un coach qui est qui est très
bon pour faire progresser les jeunes
donc individuellement il est largement
au rendez-vous et peut-être même au-delà
des attentes on pouvait croire on
pouvait croire un démarrage un peu plus
on va dire calme de la part de de Victor
wembanama maintenant on attend d'avoir
une équipe des Spurs sera pour la saison
prochaine peut-être avec un peu plus
d'éléments convaincants pour avoir des
résultats collectifs un peu plus
probants pour Victor W banama Pierre
Chevalier qu'est-ce que vous répondez
moi je je réponds donc non il est il est
pas encore dans la légende mais ça ne
serait tardé évidemment euh on sait que
on sait que Victor n'a pas eu le choix
dans la draft avec l'arrivée au spur ça
je le redis
et mais et qu'il se retrouve avec une
équipe à porter sur ses épaules qui ont
qui ont quand même pas mal pas mal qui
s'est pas mal étau fait fait au niveau
des épaules et des biceps il a pris 7 8
kg là depuis son arrivée donc là il est
il est bien pris en main euh il a des
stats qui effectivement à fol à folle
les compteurs il est pas encore dans les
dans dans les records d'un Kevin Durand
quand il a quand il a démarré aussi par
exemple mais il est il est 3e ou 4e
toute stade confondu parce que là je
dirais en fait et c'est là c'est là où
c'est là où c'est c'est un peu sou c'est
que son côté complet peut peut-être le
desservir c'estàd qu'en gros il est bon
partout et c'est un c'est un athlète de
2,25 maintenant euh avec avec ou sans
chaussures qui qui qui qui drible je
l'ai vu faire des je l'ai vu faire des
des rollover aussi autour de son corps
pour aller pour aller dunker derrière
qui qui esquive qui tire à tris points
qui est plutôt à droit au lancer franc
aussi qui donun bon ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est même voilà c'est c'est même c'est
même banal de dunkerer sur la tronche de
ses ses adversaires et euh il il est
donc il est meilleur contreur là avec
avec une moyenne de presque trois
contres par match et donc joueur complet
qui doit porter son équipe et qui là
malheureusement s blessé et c'est pour
ça aussi qu'il est rentré sans
autorisation c'est que sa cheville sa
cheville là qui s'est tordue à Dallas et
sous observations évidemment là c'est
comme si c'était son talon d'achile on a
souvent dit sur ce plateau que ce qui
pouvait ce qui ce qui ce qui guetttait
Victor et et son et son explosion et son
entrée dans la légende c'est le risque
de blessure s'il est s'il est s'il est
épargné par les blessures notamment les
blessures sérieuses bon là sauteur de la
cheville à priori c'est pas si grave que
ça il ira il ira très loin et il va il
va il va respecter les oracles et et
puis et nous faire rêver et nous emmener
le basket français là où peut-être il
n'a jamais été où il avait pris la piste
avec Tony Parker mais c'est et puis les
les rudy Gobert et autres qui sont déjà
en NBA mais mais là il est il il est en
train de prendre un départ canon il est
dans une équipe qui est en construction
comme l'a rappelé Greg Popovic va nous
va nous trouver quelque chose à nous
trouver la recette cette saison ou la ou
la saison prochaine de toute façon là
ils sont en piste les Spurs pour pour
être à nouveau pas très loin du premier
choix de la draft de l'année prochaine
he donc donc voilà il faut construire
autour de Victor et et puis et puis là
oui de toute façon si c'est pas cette
saison ça va être la saison prochaine ou
les suivantes quand il commencera à
gagner les titres Jean qui vous a
convaincu
euh moi je Seris plutôt pour pour ce
qu'a dit Pierro
euh parce que alors moi j'étais j'étais
entre les deux parce que effectivement
il est il est présent il est présent il
est au rendez-vous quoi il explose tous
les compteurs là c'est un futur grand
joueur ça c'est sûr on en est sûr
maintenant c'est un futur grand joueur
mais pour moi une légende c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait énormément euh
durant une carrière quoi on peut parler
pour moi de légende des Michael Jordan
des voilà ça ce sont des légendes parce
que ils ont ils ont ils ont fait une
carrière monumentale monstrueuse voilà
on en on envoie voilà voilà on envoie
actuellement là ça pour moi ce sont des
légendes mais on peut pas parler d'une
légende d'un jeune joueur qui débute
aussi fort que que que ces débuts c'est
sûr il explose tous les records on est
là on dit les chiffres il est présent il
est présent au rendez-vous on
l'attendait beaucoup et puis surtout moi
ce que je veux pas faire c'est le bon
français en disant en le mettant en
mettant la charue avant les B en en lui
donnant le titre déjà de légende alors
que finalement bah outre outre ses ses
performances individuel pour l'instant
il fait il fait son boulot de basketteur
il le fait très bien mais pour moi on on
est loin de de de de de lui donner le
titre de légende attendons un peu
laissonsle
progresser grand équipes Janis at tetumo
je vais réussir à le dire il est il est
au-dessus de de de joueurs comme
celui-là par exemple il tournait à
l'époque sur le même nombre de match 6,5
points lors de sa première saison 4,5
rebonds 1,5 passes sur ces sur ses
premiers matchs il est larement audessus
finalement et Janis a été MVP quelques
années plus tard d'cord on est bien
d'accord mais quelques années plus tard
donc là pour l'instant c'est un garçon
qui explose les compteur et et les
records et qui est encore une fois
présent au rendez-vous on l'attendait il
est là il répond il répond présent mais
encore une fois pour moi attendons
attendons attendons qu'il fasse vraiment
des des des sur la longueur je dirais
qui dure sur la longueur qu' inègre
peut-être aussi un peu plus tard une
grande équipe où il va pouvoir peut-être
aussi lui sortir son épingle du jeu
parce que là finalement ben on le voit
et avec ce sa blessure là tout le monde
là ça y est tout le monde est est en
alerte en haleine si on perd si on le si
on perd Victor Bama ça y est c'est fini
on on est perdu donc là c'est c'est le
le pivot de l'équipe actuellement donc
je lui souhaite c'est très bien je lui
souhaite de grandir encore plus pas en
taille parce que là sinon c'est pas la
peine mais qui grandisse
professionnellement et sportivement et
qu'il intègre des grandes équipes où là
peut-être parce que ce sera un grand
joueur c'est certain maintenant et là on
parlera peut-être d'une légende mais
pour l'instant c'est un peu trop tôt
grgor quelques un des visages Kobe
Bryant Michael Jordan Alan ierson il est
encore très loin de de ces grands noms
de la NBA la légende je suis d'accord
avec jeens se construit au fil des
années et aussi avec des titres des
titres collectifs maintenant peut-être
une légende médiatique je pense que dans
l'histoire de la NBA une pareille un
pareil engouement une pareille Mania
autour d'un joueur en plus qui n'est pas
américain qui vient de l'étranger je
pense que ça a été rarement vu dans les
dernières années ça sera le mot la fin
sur cette thématique on va maintenant
passer à notre page
débat on va terminer par l'envolet de
Gregory le meilleur moment de cettem
arde toujours le meilleur pour la fin
grgory alors de quoi allez-vous nous
parler aujourd'hui ça y est Michell ça y
est messieurs c'est cette année que la
France va accueillir les Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 une première en 100 an
pour des Jeux olympiques d'été et une
première dans l'absolu aussi pour les
Jeux paralympiques qui suivront la
capitale mais aussi les evelines vont
recevoir le plus grand des rendez-vous
moins de 200 jours désormais nous sépare
de Paris 2024 et la tente est devenue je
dois le dire insoutenable puisqueon
parle de CJO depuis longtemps
souvenez-vous c'était le 13 septembre
2017 la nouvelle était officialisée
depuis Lima au Pérou après l'échec de
2012 notre candidature française elle
n'avait pas raté le coche cette fois-ci
alors on a vu quelques images il y avait
une grande fête aussi au Vélodrome
national de 50 ans en Evelin fierté
enthousiasme était au rendez-vous et
c'est bien normal quatre sites
olympiques rien que dans l'agglomération
avec le Vélodrome et son Stadium de BMX
à montinue le Bretonneux la colline des
lencours le Golf National à agu en cours
et même un 5e site dans le département
au château de Versailles avec
l'équitation les Jeux Olympiques étaient
la promesse d'un avenir radieux c'est en
ce moment la période des vœux donc je me
lance j'espère que ces JO 2024 seront
une réussite une réussite vivre de
semaines de rêve une parenthèse
enchantée au milieu d'une actualité on
doit le dire très difficile puissent les
polémiques se calmer quelque peu autour
du rendez-vous ce budget qui déraille le
prix des plac et les incertitudes qui me
planent encore autour de la sécurité et
de certains sites et épreuves de Paris
2024 alors heureusement dans les
Yvelines pour le moment tous les voyants
semblent au vert le vélodrome national
et son Stadium de BMX sont l'expérience
des grand rendez-vous bon je parle pas
ici des championnats de France mais plus
des Championnats du Monde championnats
d'Europe qui ont prouvé la capacité de
l'enceinte à à bien recevoir on espère
aussi que niveau résultat ce sera
merveilleux des médailles d'or autour du
coup de Mathilde gr pour la piste de
Joris d'udet pour le BMX ou d'autres de
leurs acolytes accueillir des
compétitions mondiales le golf national
il a aussi goûteré j'aimerais revivre
des frissons similaires à ceux de la
rider Cup 2018 grand moment de ma vie de
jeune amoureux du sport là encore des
chances de briller avec la pépite Céline
Boutier dans le top 10 mondial
actuellement à la 3e place pareil
performance n'avait jamais été réalisé
dans l'histoire du golf français on a
aussi des sites fraîchement aménagés
pour cette échéance olympique la colline
d'élencour connaît actuellement ses
ultimes travaux d'aménagement pour les
épreuves de VTT on a eu le droit à un
avantgoût très prometteur le Test Event
qui s'est déroulé sur place en septembre
dernier avec 5000 spectateurs il y en
aura 15000 sur place les 28 et 29
juillet prochain et les ivelinois
pourront d'ailleurs profiter des pistes
de VTT même après les giio la colline
sera ouverte à tous et puis je suis
peut-être Chauvin mais on n pas très
loin de la réalité tout de même ce sera
dans les Yvelines que l'on aura l'un si
ce n'est le plus beau des panoramas de
ces Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 le
château de Versailles puisque les
épreuves d'équitation se dérouleront
directement dans le parc du château là
encore un événement test s tenu l'année
dernière sur le site qui est cette
fois-ci éphémère tout doit disparaître
après les gios l'héritage et les
souvenirs eux ne devrai pas disparaître
parce que on est on est bien loti on est
bien loti dans les ivelines aux épreuves
de cy isme sur piste de VTT de BMX
Racing de golf sont venus s'ajouter
entretemps une partie du tracé des
épreuves de cyclisme sur route et aussi
du marathon 2024 c'est l'année de
l'olympisme cela fait désormais 7 ans
Michel qu'on attend ça avec impatience
ce sera peut-être l'unique fois dans
notre vie qu'on va vivre cjodt en France
j'ai vraiment hâte on a tous vraiment
hâte bravo Grégory he toujours
magnifique on voit qu'il redémarre sur
de très grande base en 2024 Grégor canav
ne faiblit pas ne faiblit pas il ne
faiblit pas alors qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez Pierre et Jean de de cet envolé
et vous est-ce que vous avez hâte pierre
on commence par vous évidemment
évidemment j'ai hâte on en parle depuis
très très longtemps il y avait la
déception de de 2012 il y a les Jeux
Olympiques c'est une c'est une c'est une
échéance sportive à part un événement un
événement mondial
planétaire vraiment à part et et c'est
et c'est un par exemple un amoureux de
golf qui vous parle de ça en avec la
rider Cup
notamment et et puis c'est c'est surtout
notamment si si on fait le focus Eveline
c'est tellement c'est tellement de lieux
là qui vont être magnifiés par cet
événement entre le château de Versailles
entre le vélodrome entre le Golf
National la colline d' encour le le stat
de BMX il y a il y a il y a tout ce
qu'il faut pour d'ailleurs c'est je
disais il y a pas très longtemps que que
la la ville la plus courue en ce moment
sur les locations de location
saisonnière et location l'appartement ça
n'est pas Paris c'est Versailles c'est
Versailles qui est la plus courue
peut-être pour la la douceur de vivre
les panoramas dont parlait Greg et puis
toutes ces épreuves qui qui qui qui
rassemblent quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de de public international donc oui oui
vraiment hâte très hâte même si on n'
pas beaucoup de billets à très hâte que
ça que ça démarre que ça démarre en
juillet vous avez réussi à en avoir ou
pas du coup lesinois see la question
ouais is ben golf j'ai j'ai réussi à
avoir le golf par le par le le BIA le
BIA traditionnel et habituel
tout à fait je pas encore les entrées
partout Jean vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous de de cet envolé de ces Jeux
Olympique l'volé magnifique magnifique
magnifique à l'image de
Greg il a avoir des places parce qu'il a
il a loué sa maison pour pendant les
Jeux Olympiques ai aussi a pris d'or ais
d'or il peut s'acheter plusieurs places
du coup là il il a acheté il a acheté la
natation acheté les
Grad national alors c'est l'événement
planétaire que tout le monde attend tous
les 4 ans il est en France pour nous ce
sera certainement les seuls jeux
olympiques que nous verrons de notre
vivant les derniers c'était il y a 100
ans donc on ne peut que être réjoui de
cette magnifique organisation et et
d'autant plus avec tous tous les toutes
les disciplines qui ont qui vont se
disputer sur nos terres des ivelines
quoi donc on le peut dire qu'un grand
cocorico euh avec bien sûr on va pas les
bémoles tout tout au niveau du budget du
transport en le transport c'est quand
même je trouve que c'est c'est c'est un
caillou dans la chaussure ouais c'est
c'est un point noir parce que euh je
disais je crois qu'on est le le seul
pays quand même à avoir
quasiment enfin à augmenter on va pas
les chiffres avoir augmenté le le le le
le prix de des transports pour cette
manifestation olympique pour ces Jeux
Olympiques beaucoup beaucoup avaient
fait la gratuité pendant les pendant les
jeux olympiqu dans la candidature Mme
d'ailleurs ouais beaucoup avent fait la
gratuité là augmenté le prix euh c'est
vra c'est vraiment le point noir de de
de de ces Jos qui se veulent populaires
en plus donc bon déjà on av il y av eu
il y avait eu quand même cette ambigué
et ce débat autour des autour des places
parce qu'on disait qu'il y avait des
places à prix populaires sauf que pour
avoir des places à prix populaire fallit
acheter un pack complet euh de d'autres
disciplines qui vous plaisaient pas
spécialement donc bon on a joué un petit
peu sur les mots c'est un petit peu
dommage sur la communication mais ça
reste pas quand même
l'événement planétaire et cocorico c'est
en France et à Paris très rapidement un
petit tour de table quelle est l'épreuve
qui vous fait le plus rêver dans les
ivelines que vous aimeriez voir dans les
ivelines grgory
euh qui me fait le plus rêver allez je
dirais quand même j'ai hâte de voir
l'quitation au château de Versailles
voir ce que ça rend le rendu final en
fait parce qu'on en parle depuis de
nombreuses années j'ai hâte de voir ce
que ça va donner pour vous Jean allez je
mets le doigt dessus le golf Le Golf et
pour vous Natur naturellement le golf
mais je suis assez
d'accord le panorama Versailles le
panorama du château de versaill ça va
avoir de la gueule alors c'est déjà la
fin de cette émission on va terminer
comme d'habitude par une citation
aujourd'hui je vous propose une citation
du basketteur Michael Jordan n'ayez pas
peur d'échouer ayez peur de ne pas
essayer je vous laisse méditer sur cette
phrase à bientôt sur
[Musique]
tv78